did you ever have doubt in yourself I
mean especially as you gotten into the
public eye with all the attacks did you
ever doubt your ability to stay strong
to be able to be a voice of the ideas
that you represent you definitely I
don't doubt my ability to say what I
want to say I doubt my ability to handle
the emotional blowback of saying it
meaning that that's that's difficult I
mean again
in to take just one example in 2016 the
ADL measure that I was the number one
target of anti-Semitism on planet Earth
you know that's that's not fun yeah it's
unpleasant and when you take critiques
not from anti-semites when you take
critiques from people generally
we talked about near the beginning how
you surround yourself with with people
who are going to give you good feedback
sometimes it's hard to tell sometimes
people are giving you feedback you don't
know whether it's well motivated or
poorly motivated and if you are trying
to be a decent person you can't cut off
the mechanism of feedback and so what
that means is sometimes you you take to
heart the wrong thing or you take its
heart too much uh you're not light
enough about you take it very very
seriously you lose sleep over it man I
can't tell you a number of nights where
I've just not slept because of some
critique somebody's made of me and I've
thought to myself maybe that's right
maybe that and sometimes it is right and
you know that's that's some of that is
good to Stew in that criticism but some
of that can destroy you do you have a
shortcut so uh Rogan has talked about
taking a lot of mushrooms since you're
not since you're not into the mushroom
thing
um what's your escape from that like
when you get low when you can't sleep
usually writing is a big one for me so I
the writing for me is cathartic I love
writing uh that that is a that is a huge
one spending time with my family uh
again I usually have a close circle of
friends who I will talk with in order to
sort of bounce ideas off of them and
then once I've kind of talked it through
I tend to feel a little bit better uh
exercise is also a big one I mean if I
go a few days without exercise I tend to
get pretty grumpy pretty quickly I mean
I could keep the six-pack going somehow
man there you and Rogan agree